Hello everybody!
Hello!
I hope the music is not too loud because oh my god it is very loud on my end.
Hello everybody!
I cannot believe it.
We're finally going to play the best Sonic game ever created.
Which I've yet to ever... which I've never played before.
That's when you know that it is a really good game.
Because even I know this is the best Sonic game ever.
But... okay it's a little loud.
Let me turn that down.
Shit down.
Don't worry it was very loud for me too.
Look this game was made in like the 90s okay?
Like there was no like sound balancing or like mixing.
Mix... like...
Sound mixing and balancing in game was not a thing back in the 90s guys.
Just remember see it was made in 96, 97, 98 and 99.
So game... game audio balancing was not a thing back then.
The 90s were a different time guys.
Uh Mehdi thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's like a car crash I don't... what do you mean?
This... this in my opinion is...
No... I feel like in my opinion...
Sonic Dreams collection is one of the best Sonic game collection they have ever made.
Each one.
Make My Sonic, Eggman Origin, Sonic Movie Maker and my roommate Sonic.
I would say like all of them 10 out of 10.
Never played either any of them before.
But like just reading the names...
I can tell...
That it is a 10 out of 10 game.
So for those who are wondering like what is the lore behind Sonic Dreams collection?
Well...
Obviously none of us...
Uh...
Obviously like not a lot of us grew up with Sonic Dreams collection.
But I've heard that like...
These games were...
Um...
Were released only back then for like one year.
Like when it was released.
It was only out for a limited time.
So like not a lot of people were able to actually play these games back then.
In 96, 97, 98, 99.
So...
Uh...
They recently re-released it.
Like 10 years ago.
It was recently re-released 10 years ago.
So...
So those who didn't grow up back then...
Um...
To be able to play these games missed out on what was considered peak Sonic gaming.
Uh...
So...
It's been 10 years.
Yes, it has been almost 10 years since the collection came out.
Um...
Also, by the way...
So like...
Wait, who?
Sega.
So I was gonna be like, who made Sonic?
Haha...
Sega!
Uh...
Contracted...
Um...
These developers.
Because back then, Sega was like, we should hire American developers to make a Sonic game.
So...
Uh...
They contacted these developers.
And after making what was known as one of the best Sonic collection games ever...
They went on to make...
Uh...
Tattletail.
And...
Neon White.
Isn't that crazy?
I can't believe...
No wonder...
No wonder Neon White was so good.
They came from Sonic Dream Collection.
They can never miss.
They...
They don't miss!
They knew what the consumer wants back in the 90s.
And now they know what the consumer wants in the 2023.
So true!
They don't miss!
Uh...
Court Jester, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I've never heard of the best Sonic game there is.
Can't wait to experience it through you.
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I've never played this game before.
But like...
Through word of mouth from the people who played it in the 90s.
I...
I heard it was really good.
Hahaha...
I'm so happy.
I've been...
I've been wanting to play this game for a very long time.
But it was just so perfect.
That was very hard to be able to like play at its current time.
Because like...
You know, they wanted to...
They released...
They re-released it 10 years ago.
And like...
They wanna keep...
They wanna keep the peak gaming experience 10 years ago untouched.
Because you had to be there in the moment when it was released.
So it was very hard to play it now.
But now...
Now I can!
Now we get to finally experience this game with all of you.
Hahaha...
Sonic 06 is better.
Lies!
Sonic 06 wishes it was just as good as my roommate Sonic.
They wish they were just as good.
As my roommate Sonic.
My roommate Sonic.
Which I have not played before.
But I believe that my roommate Sonic has the best beginning, middle and end.
It's rich with story.
And Sonic 06 wishes it has 2% of my roommate Sonic.
It wishes it has the...
The...
Like...
It wishes it can be as good as roommate Sonic.
Oh my god.
Facts.
Hahaha...
Never played it before.
But I know it's just as good.
Hahaha...
True and real.
Is my sound guy alive?
I don't even know if my sound guy is alive.
Sound guy!
How's...
You know it's good when the roommate Sonic is alive.
The resolution is 1280x960.
Hahaha...
That's when you know.
When the resolution is pure retro.
That's when you know it's a good game.
It is.
Sound guy!
How's the sound?
Is the music good enough?
Sound guy?
Uh...
Look, look!
See?
I have like endorsements!
As a...
Turn on the super chat!
Thank you!
As a true Sonic fan, this collection was a life changing experience.
Really makes you feel like Sonic.
See?
Look at that!
Sound guy, just type to me in...
Just type to me in the chat.
Cause I have the...
You're modded so I can see it.
Thank you the super chat!
Thank you!
Look at that!
I have endorsements!
I have like witnesses!
Wait, what's that word?
Um...
What's that word when someone is vouching?
Vouchers!
I have vouchers from real Sonic fan!
Anyway, it's time to Make My Sonic.
Make My Sonic was MJ Studio's first prototype with Sega.
A Sonic OC original character creator.
MJ Studio was committed to fan self-expression.
They believed that Sonic was versatile enough for every genre.
Even sci-fi.
Originally, Make My Sonic was meant to create and upload avatars for use with every Dreamcast through SegaNet.
Sadly, no future games supported this level of creativity.
Oh my gosh.
Honestly, I feel like Sonic peaked it.
Like, Sonic peaked in Make My Sonic.
They tried to do that with the...
What was it?
The A-Force?
Sonic...
I forgot.
Remember that Sonic game they made?
Where you create your OC in Sonic?
But then it was like...
It was so bad.
Was it Sonic Forces?
Yeah, Sonic Forces.
You know?
They knew.
They knew they could never make...
Make My Sonic.
They tried to repeat perfection.
But they couldn't.
They couldn't, like, recreate perfection.
Darkblade, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Doki, when I was hoping you played more Sonic games, I really didn't mean this.
What do you mean?
Of course.
I would start off with the best Sonic game they've ever made.
Why would you say that, Darkblade?
Are you trying to say, Make My Sonic 96 where we can make our very own Sonic?
Sonic's original character is not peak gaming?
How could you say that?
We all want to have a Sonic OC.
Alright, Make My Sonic.
Let's go.
Okay.
Alright.
What do we want?
We want a small head.
Ooh.
Turtle the King.
Alright.
How about...
Okay.
Small head for small hitbox.
You know?
I'm trying to...
No headshot.
You know?
Is there yellow?
Yellow Sonic?
Alright.
Yellow Sonic.
Where?
I want to be Yellow Sonic.
Alright.
Yellow Sonic.
Okay.
Background color.
You know what?
All yellow.
That would be good.
All...
Oh, they don't even have yellow?
How can they have yellow Sonic but no yellow?
Also, is that why your colors match?
Exactly!
Yoko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Exactly, Yoko.
You're welcome.
Oh, now you're thinking Sonic right now.
Now you're thinking Sonic.
Oh, there's a yellow background!
Alright.
Oh, wait.
I can move this.
Wait.
I can pose for...
I can pose.
Can I like...
Is this all...
Okay.
I can just move this.
Alright.
I want to...
You know what?
You're levitating, Sonic.
You know you can figure out your Sonic OC?
Uh...
By like putting your name in Google and then writing like Doki the Hedgehog.
And then you can have your own very own Sonic OC.
Apparently every name has a Sonic OC at this point.
Alright.
What do I...
Okay.
He's gonna be running.
He's a runner.
Alright.
What is...
What is our...
Oh.
Okay.
Cheap.
I can't type.
Sorry.
Back in the 90s, it was very hard to code in...
It was very hard to code in like the ability to...
To type your name.
So unfortunately, there were...
They had to make like custom names for everybody.
But there were so many custom names that you can pick from that like everybody had like their own name.
Yeah.
Look.
Back in 96...
Back in 96, it was...
It was very hard.
There was only like five megabytes.
Okay?
Like each...
Each like CD for...
Oh God.
Sonic.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Many thanks.
Thank you.
Each CD for like computer gaming can only house five megabytes, guys.
So like of course, there was like no option to...
Yeah.
If you're lucky.
Five megabytes.
So back then, it's hard to code in the ability to type your name.
I'm sorry.
I can't type my name in...
In gaming.
Yeah, five whole megabytes.
Actually, I don't want this color.
Let's do like...
You know what?
I would like it to be...
Dark like my heart.
Chibi Cassidy, the Immortal Headshark.
Solar Prego Meto Zen she the King Supreme Vocaloid Hedgehog.
Yes.
Vocaloid...
Wait.
What did you...
Hey.
As we all know, Vocaloid came out in 1996.
So like, they wanted to like capitalize on the Sonic fandom because Sonic was very popular back then.
So the first prototype of Vocaloid was in Make My Sonic.
I don't know if you knew that guys.
A little fun fact!
A little fun fact.
Like before Hatsune Miku, it was...
It was...
Before... before Hatsune Miku, it was...
Sou Dino Kusumita, the rebel Vocaloid hedge girl.
But they realized that it was...
It was too long.
So they were like, why don't we combine all these letters in that name and make it Hatsune Miku.
And that's how we got our first Vocaloid.
Is that crazy?
Oh my god, that's crazy.
I can't believe we're learning so much today about Sonic history.
Yes, the Sonic lore.
Night Goldy Dio Shino the Hedge.
Alien Metal Dragon Synth the Hedgehog.
Night Cassie the Supreme Hedgehog.
Jules the Immortal Supreme Hedge...
Oh my god, there's so many possibilities.
There's so many names.
Venus Fox the Princess Hedge.
Night Nocturne the Hedgehog.
Windus the Hedgehog.
Dragon Blackles...
What the fuck is Blackles?
The Immortal Rebel Hedge.
Soul Alex the Blackles.
Rouge Silver the Vocaloid Hedgehog.
You know what?
I think we're getting so much Vocaloids that like...
Oh shit!
Sexy outfit!
Cynia the Supreme Hedge...
Okay, you know what?
I like this one.
This is my Sonic OC.
Sexy...
Just so you guys know, this is sexy.
This is like peak sexiness right there.
Okay?
This is why my stream is at least PG-13.
It's just way too hot to handle.
Anyway...
I've...
The ideal peak hedgehog right here.
Alright, photo booth time.
Okay, ring.
Oh, okay, I can throw rings at myself.
Ooh!
Okay, next cam.
Oh?
Alright, next cam.
Oh!
Nice.
Yes.
Hahaha!
That's where all the sexiness lies.
I'm really scared about taking screenshots, so I'm gonna hide my screen.
Oh, okay.
Alright, good.
Okay, I had to...
I had to make sure...
That it doesn't do anything weird.
Alright, let's take a picture.
Oh!
That's great.
I'm gonna tweet this out, guys.
Give me a sec.
Let me tweet this out real fast.
Tweet photo.
I made my own Sonic OC.
Check it out.
Thanks, Arcane Kids.
I had to connect my account.
You know what?
I'll do it.
No!
I forgot it's 96!
Sorry.
Back then...
I just need you guys to know.
Back then, there was a Twitter beta.
So, like, only people who have Sonic Dreams collection...
Only people who access Make My Sonic had the access to, like, Twitter beta.
So, like...
Hahaha!
I'm so sorry.
They first tested out Twitter on Make My Sonic.
Because they wanted to see what it was like to connect your game to, like, Twitter.
So, it was like the first Twitter connection.
I know.
Not only...
They just don't make Twitter like they do in 96.
Like, I know Wikipedia said Twitter came out after 96.
Back in 96, it was called Twitter.
I know like all these like youngins are like, what's Twitter?
Are you talking about X?
Back in 96 X was actually called Twitter And they had an exclusive deal with MakeMySonic to test out some features Where you can connect your account to Twitter.com And so so it was like the first uploading Twitter photos and it's true It's true.
You can look it up in the Sonic Wikipedia.
It's so true.
And it was uploaded to Sega net.
Well, no What do you mean?
No adapter detected.
How else would anyone know about sexy outfit?
See you the supreme hedgie How would they know?
How would all the other Sonic fanatics know about my beautiful creation?
The world must know!
Skittles, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I miss this triple-a Sonic game Sega will remain as cowards for never acknowledging this game's potential, but I know Sonic Sega music are the GOAT Thank you for the super chat!
I will not be silenced!
I'm gonna screenshot this.
I need you all to see my Sonic OC.
Give me a sec.
Let me tweet this out.
Give me a sec guys
Okay, there we go now the world knows my Sonic OC thing perfect
The world knows now The world knows now!
All right, the world must know.
I can't believe it!
I'm so sad!
I'm so sad.
Where's printable mode?
Color my OC!
Color my Sonic OC!
Guys...
It's like a coloring book!
It's literally a free coloring book.
Oh my god.
Things were so fucking better in 96 Where is my printable mode in PAL World?
Where is my printable mode in?
Sonic Forces!
In Sonic Boom!
I can't believe it!
You guys were like no Sonic 06 is a better Sonic game than make my my Sonic OC But where is my printable mode?
Huh?
Where was my...
Where is it?
How was I supposed to color Sonic the Hedgehog?
Huh?
She's got a point.
I can't believe we never had that.
Oh my god.
Anyway...
Um...
Uh... I hope you guys enjoy the first game of Sonic... of Sonic Dream Collection I hope you guys enjoy the first game of Sonic Dream Collection Sonic Dream Collection Sonic Dream Collection You know it's official when Sonic says that.
You know it's official.
I can't believe it.
I'm so sad.
My OC!
My OC's not on SegaNet!
All the other Sonic OC fans can't comment on my beautiful OC now!
I'm so... I'm so sad.
This is truly the gold era of gaming.
It can't possibly get better, can it?
Well, the great thing about these American developers is that every year they've outdone themselves.
It's actually crazy.
If you guys thought Make My Sonic was that great, you should check out Eggman Origin.
Never played it, but I assume every game gets better from what I've heard.
Almost nothing is known about Eggman Origin.
There's no surviving documentation.
From digging through the code...
We can tell it was an MMORPG.
But few have ever seen past the title screen.
Oh my god!
We're gonna be one of the few!
Guys, it is such an honor to play Eggman Origins for all of you.
The first Sonic MMORPG.
Eggman Origins.
Wait, what?
No network at all?
Network adapter connected?
How do I get this?
Wait, guys.
How do we turn on...
Wait, I didn't install the network adapter?
Guys, how do I install the network adapter?
It's so ancient!
This...
This game is so ancient!
How do I get the network adapter?
Wait...
Okay, guys.
I gotta hook it up to the top.
Yeah...
We gotta go back to 96.
We gotta go back to 96?
Oh my god!
Okay, we gotta find the network adapter.
Okay, maybe it's in make... added Twitter support.
Okay.
I have to download it?
Oh my...
Okay, wait guys.
I need to find...
Don't worry.
I've downloaded everything there is to...
When I bought Sonic Dreams Collection.
By the way, it was so difficult to like buy this collection because it's like technically like abandonware, you know?
So like I had to like go on eBay and like buy the CD to play this game.
And like I had to...
It was...
So hard to get a physical copy of Sonic Dream Collection.
And I had to spend so much money on eBay to...
Wait, I got mail?
Where did I get mail?
I had to spend so much money trying to find a physical copy.
Because it's like from 96, you know?
Like how...
Of course it's gonna be difficult.
It's literally from 96.
Alright, give me a sec.
I need to find a way to...
Okay, Sonic Dream Collection.
Where the fuck is the adapter?
Where is the adapt...
Guys, give me a sec.
I am going through some stuff because I don't know where the adapter is right now.
I don't know.
Some things are meant to be lost in...
What do you mean?
This is known as one of the best Sonic games of our generation.
And like pre-generation.
Of any generation.
It is the best Sonic game.
Ever.
Anyway, how do I get the network adapter?
How do I get the adapter?
I gotta install MSN Messenger.
The driver is in the CD.
Where in the CD?
Do I take the CD out?
It's in the game files?
Oh my god.
Okay guys, give me a sec.
Sorry.
I didn't grow up with Sonic...
It's okay.
Thank God we have people that have grown up with the Sonic Dream Collection.
That has the step-by-step guide.
Uh...
Step-by-step guide.
On how to get these games running.
Nick, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your sponsorship with Sega has been revoked because you play this game.
That is...
How could they revoke my sponsorship with Sega?
When this is an official...
An official game from Sega Company.
How is that possible?
It's one of their most...
It's one of their most well-performing games.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Everyone talked about Sonic Dream Collection.
Any naughty kids in my chat?
Tell me about your...
Tell me about your experience with the Sonic Dream Collection.
Any naughty kids in the chat vouching for me?
Okay.
Let me see.
I'm trying to figure out how the fuck to download the...
Okay.
Let me.
There's a read me text.
Clearly I didn't read the read me text.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Wait a minute.
Uh...
Hahahaha Alright.
Wait, wait.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm trying to figure out...
I'm trying to figure out how to download the adap- Guys!
I need a step-by-step guide!
How do I get the...
How do I get the adapter, guys?
Oh my god!
It did take the screenshot!
And I found the screenshot!
I found the screenshot though.
Oh, it's extra data files?
Oh my god, I'm gonna start- Okay, extra...
Unsafe file.
Wait, isn't the unsafe file used at your own risk?
Oh my god!
Alright.
We can use this.
We're gonna use at our own risk.
Okay.
After that, you'll find the- Okay.
Unsafe file used at my own risk.
Okay, I got that.
What do I do after that?
Oh my god, I already lost the step-by-step guide that you guys gave me.
Um, corrupted data.
Okay, corrupted data.
Alright.
Oh, there's a SIGNET!
I got SIGNET!
Alright, I'm installing it.
I'm installing SIGNET right now.
Okay.
We have to create a username?
Uhhh...
Joke... Jokey bird.
Um...
Don't hack into my SIGNET.
It's 1234.
Password.
Wait, it doesn't work?!
What?!
Guys!
1234, it doesn't work!
Jokey bird is already taken?!
Who took my account?!
Who did it?
The code is hidden in 98.
Alright, sorry.
Unfortunately, we won't be able to- We'll figure it out.
We'll figure it out.
We'll go to Sonic Movie Maker.
Alright.
Sonic Movie Maker was many years ahead of its time.
Technically speaking, MJ Studio envisioned a movie making program for players to explore and share their desires with the rest of the world.
Internal...
The 90s.
Jokey bird took my account.
Jokey bird from 96.
Internal notes suggest that Sega executives pulled the plug after learning about some of Sonic Movie Maker's darker subplots.
Um...
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
Those who had FOMO were able to grab a copy of Sonic Movie Maker.
So this was like a partnership with Microsoft.
Because like, you know how like some companies want to add like a little spice to like a little crossover collab?
So like Microsoft Movie Maker collabed with Sonic, with Sega, to make like a Sega skin for like Movie Maker.
So, uh...
So that's great!
It was like really easy back then.
To like make movies.
Like that.
Oh my god!
The Sonic Movie Maker!
It was the precursor for Miku Miku Dance.
Good times!
Alright.
Let's make a movie, Sonic!
Woo!
Okay, how do I play?
Apprendi...
De...
La...
Reg...
Regla...
Basic Control.
Okay.
Controls...
Basicals...
Alright.
W, A, C, Move...
Okay.
Left...
Is...
Left is grab.
Oh, left mouse click is grab.
Uh...
Middle mouse...
Middle is grab the prop.
Push and pull.
And then right is record.
Okay.
Record.
While in...
Recordo mode.
Uh...
Record...
Zoom...
Exit...
Okay, additional.
Escape, grab object and cycle filters.
What are tips?
A steady hand is the first step to a great film.
Hold right click to enter record mode and steady the camera.
Once you're done filming, walk through the red exit door to show Sonic you're satisfied with the day's shoot.
Uh...
While grabbing the prop, you can use the scroll wheel to pull or push it.
Use the E key to grab objects while filming.
Uh...
Sonic and his pals love touching different props.
Experiment to find out.
Right, witch.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sonic Dreams Collection marked the end of my childhood innocence.
After playing it, I was no longer a mere girl.
I was a hedgehog.
And I was fast.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look at that.
A 90s kid vouched for my...
For this game.
You can always trust 90s kids.
They've been through a lot.
I'm not kidding.
Alright, let's go to the backyard.
Whoa!
This sensitivity.
Welcome to Sonic Movie Maker.
Left click, and scroll, okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Hello, Sonic.
Whoa!
This sensitivity, though.
Can I grab this?
No, I can't.
Can I grab Sonic, though?
Okay.
Right click to focus.
Left click while focus is recorded.
Alright, Sonic.
I'm gonna grab you real quick.
Alright, we're gonna have you...
We're gonna have you on the car.
Now be... Whoa!
Sonic, I need you on top of the car!
Sonic, please!
Wait, is that a diaper?
Sonic?
Is that... is that Sonic?
Wait, when you're done walk through the exit to walk in.
Alright.
Oh, hey there is!
Toss a ball, Dad!
Okay, I love my dad.
Alright, let's make a story.
Alright, Sonic.
I need you to... Okay, here we go.
I need you to stay here.
Alright?
Alright, Sonic?
I need you to say, I love my dad.
Alright?
But we all know you have daddy issues though.
Alright.
Here we go.
I love my dad.
Alright, and then...
And then...
What happens is that...
Is that you throw a ball...
Oh my God!
We throw the ball up in the sky.
Wait, where did the ball go?
Wait, where the fuck did the ball go?
Wait...
What the fuck?
Alright, alright, the ball is gone!
The ball is now gone forever!
Alright... Oh, there's the ball!
Okay, okay, we're gonna put you under the car.
Um, because a car... You got...
Now you have... You're gonna commit insurance fraud.
Cause dad suggested you to commit some insurance fraud.
Cause dad is not doing so well financially right now.
So, we have to film this for insurance.
Alright, we're gonna put you under here.
How do we lead from insurance fraud to playing catch?
It's alright.
This is a very low budget film.
Alright, nice.
Good job, Sonic.
This is fun!
Alright!
And I'm done.
Wait.
Yeah, and I'm done.
Exit.
How do I leave?
Oh, I have to film fully?
Okay, what else can we do?
Wait, what's over here?
Wait, I came from here.
Alright, and now we'll fix it in post.
Yeah, we're gonna fix this in post.
Shadow, thank you for the aqua soup!
Thank you, thank you!
It's like taking candy from a baby.
Which is fine.
It's fine by me.
And then after that...
After that...
You just wanna go home.
You're done.
You just wanted to go home.
You didn't wanna be here anymore.
Yay!
Film's done!
Head for the exit!
Alright.
This is a snail dog!
The feeder is sold out?!
Oh my god!
Let's go home!
Look at that!
I love my dad.
This is fun.
Let's go home.
Isn't that great?
I'm so proud of Sonic.
What a beautiful movie.
It got sold out too!
Oh my god!
I am a great director.
Alright, next scene.
Absolute cinema right there.
Pull me.
Alright.
What is this?
Oh!
It's Promete!
Promete!
Don't worry so- Okay, I need to know if I can adjust the sensitivity.
Sonic!
It's time!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
It's okay.
You're gonna be...
Oh my god!
Rouge the Bat too!
Oh my god, Sonic!
You know how to pick women!
Wait, you're like stuck to each other.
Wait, this is not good.
Wait.
Guys!
You're not supposed to be stuck to each other yet!
Not yet!
Okay.
Let's dance.
And then we're gonna have close-up.
We're gonna have a close-up shot.
Of a pineapple for like...
And also the ice cream.
Yes, yes.
A close-up shot of the ice cream.
Oh my god.
Perfect.
Alright, and then after that...
Let's have like a side shot from the side as if I'm like...
A voyeur right here.
Ooh, yeah.
You go, Sonic.
Like right here as if I'm a voyeur.
And then we'll slowly scroll closer.
And...
There you go.
It's good.
There.
No, I'm kidding.
Why?!
What do you mean?!
Wait, there's more?!
Oh!
Oh, I have filters!
Oh my god, I have filters.
I forgot about that.
I forgot about...
Oh my god.
I forgot about the filters...
Okay.
Alright.
It's good that I didn't find any.
It's good that I didn't find these.
Okay, let's head out to the exit.
Alright.
Let's leave, guys.
I'm glad I- Wait, there's more!
What's this?
That is...
Did they just take a picture of me?
Alright, what's this?
Okay.
It's alright, we're good.
This film is over.
Oh, I should put in night vision.
I know.
Now that I know...
Now that I know there's like filters, we can have like black and white films.
To show that it's like, you know...
Uh...
It's a hit!
I knew it!
Oh, it's perfect!
I can have black and white films, cause they're extra classy.
It's extra classy, you know?
That's like Oscar worthy right there.
Chat, it's Oscar worthy when you know it's black and white.
Film noir!
Exactly!
Right there.
I knew I had some cinema fanatics right there.
And I know exactly what I'm...
Oh.
Oh, it's a hotel.
That's classier than a motel.
You know?
Good for them!
Good for them that they can afford a hotel instead...
Why is there a...
What was this?
Why is there a van here?
Good for them that they can afford a hotel.
Instead of a motel.
Um, cause it's like prom night, you know?
There...
Oh, no.
It's university prom night.
It's...
It's university...
Wait, check the alley?
What's... Where's the alley?
Where's...
Where's... Is this the alley?
What's in the alley?
Guys, we don't hear anything in the silence.
Guys, don't worry.
Is this...
Is this the alley?
We'll check the room later.
I just...
Wait, who the fuck is that?
Who are you?
Hello?
You're an egg!
Is this Eggman Origins?
I love Tails.
But I'm so shy.
Who are you?
Iggy?
Oh, God.
I thought I...
Oh, my God.
That scared me.
I thought like I...
He like teleported in front of me.
Oh, my God.
Astro, thank you for the one gifted chip.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
I thought he actually teleported in front of me.
I was gonna be like, holy shit.
That's his lore.
He likes Tails.
Alright, here we go.
Let's head up.
Modern Sonic games would never do stuff like this anymore.
They don't...
They don't like fucking...
You know...
Go out of their comfort zone.
It makes me so upset.
Wait, Tails?
Tails?
What's going on, Tails?
What's going on?
Oh, okay.
Film noir.
Wait.
Wait, this is worse.
No way.
Oh, my God.
Shadow?
Whoa.
But what about...
Oh, okay.
Okay, we got it.
I'm gonna...
Okay, because I feel bad for you, Tails.
Alright.
Alright, we're gonna put you in there.
Tails, I feel so bad for you.
Don't...
Yeah, Tails.
Oh, my God.
.
What's this?
Wait.
Actually...
Get Tails out of here.
Actually, no.
Amy...
Wait.
We're attached to somebody?
No, you're not.
Alright.
Here we go.
Alright, you're gonna be in the corner.
Tails is...
You're subbing out for Tails.
Right here.
You're subbing out for Ta...
Tails wanna have fun.
Okay.
Not this...
Alright.
There you go.
Nice.
Okay, I'm lonely.
And now, we gotta have close-ups of this...
Of this very fun time.
Wait!
Sonic, no!
That's Tails!
Wait, bring Tails to Iggy?
Alright, Tails.
Alright, we're gonna include a surprise third.
Alright, Tails, come over here.
We're gonna give you love.
We're gonna find you love!
It's alright.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
As we all know, Sonic characters are always thinking about protection.
Guys, don't worry.
Stay safe, kids.
Um, college students.
Stay safe!
Cause this is university prom night!
Stay safe, university students!
Alright, Iggy, get over here.
Get over here.
Alright, here you go, Iggy.
Here you go.
My dream co- What the fuck is that?
Why is there a fire with hearts?
Oh my god.
What the fuck is this?
Are you happy now, Mr. Iggy?
Can I bring this over?
Oh, haha.
Firey passion.
Doll, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, this is so trippy.
It's burning.
What is this game?
It's the best Sonic game they've ever made!
What do you mean?
This is the best Sonic game that's ever created.
God, I can't- Why would I need to remind you guys over and over?
You can tell this is a really good game.
Like, you can tell.
There should be no reminding you of this.
Of this fact.
This was our childhood.
When we were university students.
University childhood!
Alright.
What was this movie like?
Whoa.
Look at that.
The close-up!
The fucking- Okay.
The close-up is really good.
I really like the choice of that.
I really- I think like I outdid myself with the close-up.
I'm not even kidding.
I'm not kidding.
I think this is the best one yet, honestly.
Alright, next scene.
Wait.
Try using E.
Wait, what?
Where's the camera?
Huh?
Oh.
But, where's the camera?
Sonic?
You're not Sonic 2?
What's going on, Sonic?
Oh!
Where's my- Where's my camcorder?
Where- Oh!
There it is!
Oh my god!
Thank god!
I thought I was gonna miss out!
Oh, thank god!
Okay, thank- Okay, now we're fine.
Alright.
Getting a close-up of your stomach to know that...
Uh...
To know that it's growing.
Oh, thank- Thank god!
Okay, I thought I was gonna miss out.
I thought I was gonna miss out on this recording.
I think-
I'm so happy I- I got this!
Alright.
Ooh.
Yeah, yeah, like that.
And then...
Uh, we need the grainy.
Feed me more...
There we go.
And then close up here.
Feed me more...
Nice.
Alright, and then now we're gonna feed you.
We're gonna feed you now.
Alright, do you like...
Here you go.
Ooh!
Look at that!
I think we can keep feeding you, Sonic!
Are you hungry?
Eat up!
Eat up and be a good boy!
Eat up, Sonic!
Ooh, nice!
Alright, I think we can keep feeding you.
Come on!
You can get bigger than that, Sonic!
Eat it for the Oscars!
Don't you want a Golden Globe, Sonic?
You know you want a Golden Globe!
Please don't keep- don't!
Guys, this is important!
We won an Oscar!
Oh...
You want more?
He did say he wanna feed me more- No!
Is that- oh, good, okay.
I thought they were gonna cut me off.
Come on, Sonic!
You know you want more!
Oh!
Nice, okay.
There we go.
Nice.
Alright.
They took it away!
Oh, Tails!
Happy birthday, Tails!
Can I feed Tails?
Will you eat Tails?
You're not gonna eat Tails- Alright.
Alright.
Alright, I'm gonna leave now.
I think we saw the movie.
I think we saw the movie!
Oh like, it gives me chills!
Look!
Feed me more.
Yes!
Feed me more!
Okay, the glitch effect is actually really good.
Not gonna lie, the glitch effect really sells this for me.
I'm honestly improving more and more as a director.
Cass, it's better not wake up when something is in me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not gonna lie, I think I'm... Oh my god!
Is someone Pregante?
Who's Pregante?
Who's the father?
Shadow?
Where's the camera though?
Where's the camera?
Oh god, wait, wait, don't do anything Sonic!
Not yet!
Sonic!
Sonic, not yet!
I need to find the camera!
No, not yet!
Please stop smashing the glass, never.
There it is!
Oh my god, there we go.
Okay, I got the camera.
Okay.
I'm not the father.
I'm the father.
Who's gonna be the father?
Alright guys, who's gonna be the father?
It has to be Eggman!
Let me in!
I need to get to Eggman!
Right now!
Get over here!
This is for my movie!
Give me Eggman!
Eggman, we need you to be the father!
Get over here!
I'm casting you as the father!
Okay, alright.
You can sort of see it here.
There we go.
Alright, this works.
I'm the father.
Alright, ask me how to avoid rashes.
Okay.
Alright, that's good enough.
Uhh...
We'll put... It's not easy being pregnant right here.
And then I'm gonna put a filter.
Uhh...
Let's see, it's not a horror film anymore so we should do black and white.
It's a black and white film!
Right now, okay.
This is gonna be Oscar worthy.
This is what's gonna get me an Oscar!
We're gonna put this in Best Director of 2024.
Alright, it's not easy being pregnant.
Alright, and then...
And then we're gonna be... Amy's gonna be like...
Right after like, we smash through this...
Came out!
Oh my god!
The child comes out and then Amy's gonna be like...
Great job, Sonic!
Okay.
Alright, I gotta make sure I get this.
Wait, no?
Come on.
Oh, nice!
We got it!
We got the shot!
Oh my god!
And it's the...
And it's the only shot that's in color.
This is gonna be the only shot that's in color.
And then...
Okay.
Get...
Get me out of here!
Okay, we're gonna close up on this.
There we go.
Okay, wait, we're gonna move this closer...
To where the baby's coming out.
And then...
Okay, no.
The angle's not right.
Here.
This is where the angle's gonna be.
Alright.
Get me outta here.
Good?
Alright, here we go.
Wait, actually I need...
I need to move here more.
There we go.
Get me outta here.
Alright, one more.
That has to be the last one, right?
Oh!
And it was Tails all along!
What?
Congratulations!
Eggman and Tails!
Okay.
It's a miracle.
The miracle of childbirth.
Oh my god.
So beautiful.
So fucking beautiful!
It's true.
It truly is a miracle!
How do I get out?
Rated E for...
By the way, this game was like rated E for everybody, guys.
Writer, thank you for the 10 gifted chips!
Thank you, thank you!
Doc, thank you for the super chat!
Truly a cinematic masterpiece.
A24 would never be a director dokey.
Patient...
Wait.
What Rouge the Bat, Nitecore?
What is going on?
There's more?
I don't have enough film!
Wait a minute.
Oh, wait a minute...
Oh no!
Where am I?
Hahaha!
Oh my god, but look at this.
Oh my god, it's not easy!
Okay, that shot with the chow was really good.
That shot with the chow...
I would say I actually captured...
I filmed that scene perfectly.
Oh my god.
You can feel the trauma and the intensity of everything right now.
You can really feel it, guys.
You can capture those moments.
Oh my god.
Oscar nominee right there.
Username, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is a weird Yakuza side quest, Sega.
Look, Yakuza took its inspiration from Sonic Movie Maker.
You guys didn't know that.
Look, a rowdy crowd!
Oh no.
Look, I got an emerald.
Yay!
Wow, this is a really...
This is a really damn game.
Guys!
Hello, Iggy.
What do you want, Iggy?
Guys, it's just...
It's just a really damp cave, guys.
It's just...
Look at this beautiful cave that I'm in.
Okay, because we're in a cave, we need to use the grainy film.
Oh my god.
Look at that.
Let's do a close-up of this.
Of this dilating cave.
Holy shit.
You know, I really hate it when my cave walls starts...
Oh no.
Which way does this go?
God, don't you hate it when you're exploring the cave and it gets like super...
What the fuck is that?
Big?
Big the cat?
What are you doing here?
Oh my god!
What the fuck are you doing here?
Why are you doing my cave?
Why are you...
It's okay.
We're gonna...
We're fine.
We're gonna... We found a cave exit, guys.
We found...
Where did the cave go?
Oh my god, where did the cave go?
Guys!
Wait, what?
What does that say?
Smile for mommy?
Oops, did you have an accident?
Okay, let's just pull this closer to me.
Alright.
Okay.
Alright, and then...
And then we'll have Tails over here.
And be like...
Wait, what the fuck are you guys...
You guys just got bored.
What are you guys doing?
Mama!
Alright!
Guys!
I found the cave's exit, guys!
Whoa!
Wait, what's over there?
I can't see that.
What is that?
What the fuck is that?
I'm trying to scroll... scroll!
Get over here!
I wanna know what that says!
Will I ever figure out what that says?
I can't pull it closer!
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, it's getting closer, it's getting closer!
What is this?
What does it say?
We want nothing more...
I guess we'll never know what that said.
I guess we'll never know.
I...
Yes!
I don't know.
I guess we'll never know, guys.
We'll never know!
Alright, this one's not my best work.
I'll have to admit.
This one was definitely not my best work.
I could have done so much better.
I... I...
There was a lot going on.
There were too many producers!
Okay, guys?
Too many producers were in the room!
Not my best work!
Sorry, you...
Thank you!
Look!
A voice actor!
Who has lots of experience!
Being in, like, top-rated games!
Can tell when this is a masterpiece!
That's when you know it's good!
That's when you know it's good, guys!
I'm so sorry!
That is literally an endorsement right there!
They were in Genshin Impact!
Genshin endorsed this!
The testimonial!
Wtf?
Oh, that's a rap!
Nice.
Okay.
Wait, don't say that!
Don't say that!
I can't believe it!
The Doki Bird endorsed by Genshin Impact as one of the best directors out there.
With this as my proof.
Okay, I don't know what signed guestbook is so I'm a little worried.
I'm gonna cover this real quick.
Signed guestbook.
Oh, your connection is not private.
Okay, I'm not gonna sign anything.
Guys we're not gonna sign anything.
Don't say that!
Guys, I'm not gonna sign anything at the moment.
So we're not going to...
We're not going to...
I went to the website and it was like your connection is not private.
And I was like...
That's...
That's weird.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna go back to the title screen.
Sonic Dream Team!
Yay!
Woo!
Download content?
Wait!
If I sign in, do I get the content?
Do I get the content?
Hahaha.
So how do I...
Guys.
So how...
How do I...
Get my adapter?
Get me the adapter.
Alright.
Here we go.
I told you every game just gets better and better.
Guys, how do I get my adapter, guys?
How do I get my network adapter?
Where's the password?
What the fuck is the password?
You guys said I would find the password and username in Sonic Movie Maker.
Oh, is it from my roommate Sonic?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
That's fine.
We'll do their best game yet.
Um...
This was considered the best game they've ever made in the collection.
From what I've heard.
Okay.
I'm gonna make sure I like...
I like write this down.
So...
My roommate Sonic 99 is considered one of the best games they've...
Uh...
They've ever...
They've ever made in this collection.
Um...
I've never played this before.
But I assume that it's considered better than Sonic Movie Maker.
So if it's better than Sonic Movie Maker...
Then this might be true peak gaming at that point.
Uh...
This game was my childhood.
See?
Look at that!
This person seems like somebody that's played my roommate Sonic made in 1999 at least like a hundred times.
Also, back then they were like testing out the Oculus Rift back then in 1999.
So...
In 1999, the first Oculus Rift prototype was used to test out my roommate Sonic.
If you guys didn't know that.
It's a little fun fact.
A little...
A little small fun fact chat.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Thank you Director Doki for bringing me this game.
Thank you for giving Sonic Dreams Collection to a modern audience.
God save us all.
Don't worry 90's kid.
I knew you guys want this.
Alright.
Oh, hey Sonic.
Hey there.
Oh, you and me?
Whoa!
Have you told your roommate how you feel about them?
Um...
Do I take the call?
Oh...
I don't believe you?
Okay.
Seize life.
Hold up one second.
Look out your window?
Oh shit!
Eggman my homie!
Just follow my lead.
Okay.
Okay Eggman.
What do I do?
What do you do bro?
Give him the tickles?
Okay.
Is this like...
Is this...
We're watching hedgehogs.
Naked hedgehogs.
Are we watching...
Are we watching porn?
Sonic?
Is this...
What?
Oh...
Do I tickle you?
Am I tickling you right now?
Are you...
Are you feeling a little ticklish, Sonic?
How do I tickle...
I'm clicking!
Instructions unclear!
Oh...
I'm sorry.
I should have asked...
I should have asked permission.
I'm so sorry.
Come on, Sonic.
Don't you want to get tickled?
Yeah, you do.
Oh!
Go for the kill!
What does that mean?
Oh!
But he doesn't like it!
Sonic, can I tickle you?
Okay.
Oh!
Sonic, please!
Please, you know you want the tickles!
What is this?
What is my life now?
What is...
Oh!
I'm so sorry.
You are so happy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
Okay, I'm going to do it.
Give him the tickles, Doki.
Why is his feet like this?
It's supposed to be cute!
Look at his feet!
Oh, my God.
Where did the rings come from?
Oh.
He's staring deep in the air.
Look at his eyes!
Big Ben!
Are you watching this you sick fuck?
Oh...
You taking it... No!
It's too far!
Too far!
Oh my god.
It's me.
Never go...
Never go full tickle.
Guys, here's a lesson to all of you.
I hope this is what you wanted.
Yay...
Guys, I realized why the music is playing all the time.
It's because I've been on the Sega network this entire time.
Bonus Siege Unlocked!
So that's why we're getting double the music.
I am so sorry.
Wait, I missed the password!
It's okay.
That's why we were having double the music.
We had the Sega network on this entire time.
So we were getting two music.
It's okay.
It works.
It worked in the end.
Alright, Sonic movie.
We got Bonus Siege!
Bonus Siege!
I thought it was intentional.
What's the Bonus DLC?
What is it?
Roommates?
Oh, we're just roommates guys.
Whoa!
Wait, how do I get there?
We're just very...
We're just like best friends.
Wait, how do I...
Grab...
How do I grab this?
Give me the camera.
I want the camera!
How do I grab the camera?
But I want...
Whoa!
I want to film things!
Oh my god, they're looking at me.
How do I...
How do I get the camera?
Sonic!
What do I do?
Do I just...
Okay.
We'll use this and push it.
Oh!
Your entire head!
Okay.
Alright, I figured it out guys.
Oh!
Wait, what?
Give me the head.
Okay, here you go.
Alright.
I'm holding it...
I'm pulling it back to me.
I'm pulling it back.
Yes!
Alright.
There we go.
Nice.
Wait, there's another egg!
There's another egg over there!
Wait, but like...
How do we make this a story?
You're not going to be tickling anymore!
You're not...
How is this a story?
You're not tickling anymore!
Alright.
Oh.
Yeah, this...
This feels right.
This...
Okay.
Oh my god, I can play Snake!
Okay, this is going to be the...
This...
This is the movie!
Oh!
Guys, guys, I'm gonna be streaming... Hello everybody, my name is Dokibird.
And today, we're gonna be playing Snake in Sonic Dreams Collection.
First off, I broke the key... okay, here we go.
Alright.
Nice.
There we go.
Look at me.
This is my 2007 Let's Play.
You know what?
That's great.
I think that's good.
I think that's a good film.
Oh my god!
Good Special Effects Award!
Let's go!
Do you guys like my 2007 Let's Play video?
Right here.
Sorry, 1999.
1998!
I forgot, sorry.
Sonic Movie Maker came out in 1998.
Did you guys like my 1998... 1998...
Sonic Let's Play video, guys?
Nice.
Okay, Rap Party...
Is this the same party?
The first Let's Play.
I basically made the first Let's Play.
It takes a village!
Alright, we did it.
Alright, now... now we should be able to down...
Now we should be able to make my Sonic OC.
Okay, I saved... somebody gave me the username and password.
Do not worry.
Someone paid $5 for this.
Someone paid $5, so we got this.
Alright, log in.
Allow access, please.
I'm launching the servers.
Whoa!
Can't see all this happening right now.
But a lot of stuff is happening.
Whoa!
Downloading so many things!
You hear that?
That's me downloading stuff right now.
10, 40, 50, 60, 70, 80!
90!
100!
Do I have it?
Server launch operation complete!
Warning.
It's running at full speed.
Is that it?
That got it to work?
Can I... can I get in now?
Can I...
Message of the day.
March 15th, 1998.
Who... I don't even want to say this name out loud.
I don't...
Some guy...
That's what it says.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, let me upload my OC again.
We'll test it out.
We'll test it out by uploading my OC.
Alright.
I still...
Do we still...
We still have her!
Oh my god.
She's still there.
Wait, I think it got uploaded!
It is!
Oh my god.
We have...
We have sexy outfit.
Oh my god.
This is it.
We're in.
Alright.
The big finale.
The unreleased...
Sonic MMORPG.
Wait, what do you mean no character data?
What do you mean?
What about sexy outfit?
Heh heh.
She's real to me.
She's real.
Heh heh heh.
You need the code?
Make another?
I have to...
I have to upload my OC.
But like, how?
It's not there anymore.
It's not there.
Heh heh heh.
Where did the upload go?
Where did it go?
Heh heh heh.
Oh, I just need to take a screenshot.
Okay.
I almost forgot.
Where's the back?
Ooh, okay.
A little bit...
The leg kicking out right here.
And then, boom.
There it is!
Okay, I'm gonna upload it.
I'm really worried, so I'm gonna unhide that real fast.
I'm gonna hide that real fast.
Oh, it just says this.
Upload success!
There we go.
Yay!
Sexy outfit!
Let's go!
Alright.
Now we have our character.
Here we go.
Eggman origin.
What happened to your body?
Your body!
How can you be sexy without a body?
Alright, log in.
Where am I?
Is this me?
It's me.
Where can me go?
What's going on?
Hello?
Hello there!
Hello!
Sexy legs!
Even better!
But where's my butt?
Hello?
What are you supposed to do?
Eggman?
Where do I go?
Where's sexy outfit gonna go?
Am I...
Am I going the right way?
Guys, anyone else create an account?
In Eggman origins?
Did anyone else?
Did anyone else create an account?
Sure that you guys know where to go, right?
I like how it sounds like, I got banned.
Sorry, we can't help you.
Wait, let me...
I'm gonna turn off the...
Sega net.
Surely somebody's on...
Where are all my friends at?
The shuttle loop is an enigma.
I'm a hundred years old.
Oh, okay.
Where am I?
Where...
Where do I go?
Oh...
Where...
Where do I go?
Where do I go, Mr. Eggie?
Mr. Eggie, I'm lost!
I'm lost!
Okay.
Maybe it's this way.
It has to be this way.
Where else can we go?
Is it this way?
Oh, there's another Mr. Eggie!
Oh!
Get me out of the void!
Now we're both lost.
Pessimistic Egg.
We can't be lost!
We just have to go up!
The never-ending expanse is kind of scary.
Is that...
Am I going the right way?
Is this it?
Is this a new Spore sequel?
No, Spore is the sequel to Eggman Origins, guys.
Spore is the sequel to Eggman Origins, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Oh, that's the wall!
I think the worst part is that I can't see anything.
I can't see anything.
Oh, I can't see!
Oh, it was on my leg!
Oh, no!
I'm so tired!
I need to get up!
And someone get me out!
No wonder they cancelled.
Oh god, oh god.
This is like a dark journey into limbo.
The realm between heaven and hell.
A purgatory for Sonic fans.
Boynton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hit towards your camera?
Okay, you're right.
You're right.
I'll eventually find my way.
If I keep walking backwards...
There has to be another egg somewhere!
This is what my sleep paralysis even looks like.
We're in Canada.
Oh my god.
Bro, this map is huge!
This is an MMORPG!
Oh my god, Final Fantasy wishes it can be just this game.
Oh my god, another egg!
Another egg!
Friend?
Friend!
Where am I?
I tried to take a nap in the shade, but I can't sleep.
Friend!
Where am I, friend?
Wait, do I follow the shadow?
Maybe if I follow the shadow...
Wait, click the cloud.
What's the cloud?
Where did the cloud go?
Oh, what's that?
The fuck is that?
I feed Mr. Egg!
Oh my god, I know now!
I know now!
Don't worry!
Don't worry, Eggman!
I'm gonna make you big and strong!
Oh my god, I know now!
I know now!
The objective!
My purpose in life!
Alright, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Don't worry, now I know why I'm all eggs!
Now I know why!
Iggy!
Eggman, where are you?
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
Here you go, child.
Oh, he's turning big!
He's a big boy now!
Karin, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I don't think my dreams are gonna be pleasant tonight.
What are you guys talking about?
We're talking about...
Don't you wanna tickle Sonic?
Don't you wanna tickle him?
I'm a little lost.
Is this where my child is?
Here we go.
Become big and strong for sexy outfit!
Whoa!
Okay!
She's definitely becoming big and strong.
I wonder if there's any clouds in the back.
Are there any clouds in the back?
Or is it all forward?
This is the real DokiBree simulator.
What are you going to say?
Treat an egg baby good to get an award.
Nyle, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
This game was made before yellow paint guides.
And it is a masterpiece for it.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
We are the worms!
Guys!
It's just the void!
Oh!
There's a worm!
There's a worm right there!
Worm!
I need to feed my baby egg!
Get over here worm!
Boop!
Alright.
Nice.
Back to Mr. Egg Man.
I wish I could run.
I wish I could run faster.
This is the dragoons origin story.
Sorry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Magenta super!
Thank you!
Dear Miss DokiBird.
My therapist will be hearing from this.
What?
Because you had a great time?
I did.
Alright.
Here we go.
This is all?
Do you need more worms?
Are you big and strong now?
Oh!
Do we need more?
Where am I going to get more?
Where am I going to find more worms?
Where am I going to get more worms?
You have so many worms!
I was trying to think of what I should get.
Oh yes!
There is more!
I'm just an ordinary working bird mom!
Where else can I find more worms?
Okay, here we go.
There's another worm.
Alright, here.
Is that it?
How much more?
How much more do you want?
Hector, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Psychologist, all dreams have meaning.
My dreams.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, where did he go?
Am I going the right way?
Oh, it's this way.
Okay.
This is where he is.
Alright, here we go.
Is this it?
Are you good now?
Are you full?
More?
Do you want...
Do you want more?
Where am I gonna find more?
I defeated six?
How many did I get?
Wait, how many did I get?
Oh my god, I've lost count.
I've lost count.
How much more do I need?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just join.
I feel like I need it.
I have found four?
Oh my god, this is...
This is stupid.
Why can't the worms just come to me?
There's one.
There's one right here.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's one here.
Okay.
Don't worry, we got this.
We got this.
Don't worry, Eggman.
Mama's coming back with another worm.
Child care is not stupid.
Look, you don't understand how hard it is to be a single bird mom.
You don't know the hard life it is.
Why are you... Why are you trying to find...
Going out there in the void.
Trying to find six fucking worms.
For your demanding egg child.
There you go.
One more.
It takes a village.
Exactly.
It takes a fucking village.
Oh my god.
My Sonic OC was supposed to be in the void to be sexy.
Not to find worms.
Right side.
Okay.
To the right.
Here I go.
Where is this worm?
Now she's all...
Oh, there it is.
There's the last one.
There you are.
I'm coming over.
Get over here.
Oh my god.
There it is.
The final worm.
The final worm for my child.
It's coming.
Don't worry.
Mama's coming to feed ya.
Okay.
I think I'm going the right way.
Finally.
Your OC is looking sexy finding worms.
Okay.
There's a lot to unpack there.
That's a lot to unpack there.
Sir.
Alright.
Here it is.
Here we go.
Eggman.
Eggman, I got your worm.
Your final worm.
Are you happy now?
Oh.
What the fuck is...
What?
Oh my god.
Now he's...
Now he's a mama too.
He gave birth to a fucking podium.
I'm so proud of you.
I'm a grandma now.
Look at that.
I got my own...
I got my own grandson.
He's got a chair.
Oh my god.
Look at him go.
Now he's also a single parent.
Like what?
What?
What are you doing?
Are you...
What?
One out of a thousand players.
Oh, Sonic has ascended.
You have one ascension.
God in the sky.
Submit your name to paradise.
What was it?
sexy outfit?
Oh.
Oh, I can only... I can only have like five characters, guys.
So I'm gonna submit this.
Sexy...
Oh god!
That's gonna be my name, guys.
That's gonna be my name.
Apparently I can't have more than five characters.
So that's gonna be my name.
That's gonna be my name.
Yay!
We did it!
Oh, is my audio cutting in and out?
Did the game break my audio?
No, it's okay on my end!
On my end it's okay!
The stream was like...
Is it better now?
Holy shit!
Holy shit, is it better now?
I ascended so hard.
The stream died.
I ascended the YouTube...
Fuck!
The...
I...
I ascended and then the game just shut down.
The YouTube just shut down.
They're like, we can't handle this anymore.
Wow!
That was it!
That was the Sonic Dream Collection.
I am so happy to be able to share this game with all of you!
I...
The game couldn't handle it.
Yeah!
I enjoyed my stay.
I'm so happy to share you a game from the 90s.
I know.
You guys all keep saying, Doki, we want you to play retro games.
Doki, when are you gonna play retro games again, Doki?
Look, see?
I literally played four retro games for all of you.
All in one stream.
And I shared with you...
I shared with you the best Sonic game that was ever made for the Sonic franchise.
It was really exciting.
I'm really happy to be able to share this with all of you.
I think, I think like, not gonna lie, my director skills, 10 out of 10.
I think I like improved so much.
I improved so much in directing and like, um, and like producing and like camera angles and the Dutch angle and film noir.
Oh my God.
All of those scenes, 10 out of 10, honestly.
10 out of 10.
Honestly.
Oh my God.
Holy shit.
I'm happy to be able to share it with you guys.
That was like honestly one of the, one of the games that I've always wanted to play on stream.
So I'm glad that...
Yeah, every, every, every level, I just get better and better and better in the whole like film, like in the whole like film industry.
I just kept getting better and better and better.
Uh, Zonerman!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I feel fed.
Thank you, Doki.
True cinnamon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Igor, thank you for the five gift that shows.
Shadow, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi Doki.
Today is finally my birthday.
I love your streams.
It fills my day with laughter.
You get happy birthday in Cantonese.
Thank you for today's stream.
Thank you for the super chat, Shadow.
Uh, sci-fi law.
Um, I am, it's a little concerning that...
I can't...
Actually, no, it's a gift.
It's a gift that on your birthday, you get to watch this stream.
This is the stream that was made for your birthday.
You should be honored to be able to watch this on your birthday.
Um, not gonna lie.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Shadow.
Yay!
Max!
I really got, never really got art games until now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, so...
Honestly, honestly, best, uh, I wish AAA games were made like this again.
Uh, I feel like, not gonna lie, like, a lot of AAA games, they just, they just can't do it.
Like, they used to be able to make games.
A lot of AAA, they just fell off.
They just don't know what the audience really, don't know what gamers actually want these days.
You know?
AAA game titles.
So it's really nice to go back to like when games were actually fun.
Oh my god, it's really great to relive back in the days when they just knew what we wanted.
They just knew exactly what we wanted in a AAA game title.
And back then, Sega knew exactly what Sonic fans, um...
Um, wanted in a game title.
And that's why Sonic 3 Collection is Game of the Decade in the 90s.
Yeah.
When they...
Especially my roommate, Sonic.
Sonic fans rejoice.
When Sega...
Finally...
Subcommed to the Sonic fandom's demands.
You know that all Sonic fans back then, in 1999, were so fucking happy about my roommate, Sonic.
It was a...
It was truly a Christmas gift for all Sonic fans.
When will we ever get Sonic Dreams remake?
SEGA!
You're out here remaking, remastering so many Sonic games.
I want a remaster of Sonic Dreams.
Alright?
That's all I want.
In life.
Nick, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is why the Dreamcast found us a console.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm still trying to figure out what I was watching.
Peak gaming.
That is what you were watching.
I know like it's hard to recognize it because of all the garbage we've been given over the recent years from gaming companies.
But like...
I know like you have like a little bit like some Stockholm syndrome at the moment from like all the fucking slop we've been given from like AAA gaming.
Back then!
That is what we call real game.
A real game.
A real video game.
And all that entire collection in the 90s was just $599.
Is that crazy?
It wasn't $40 with like a $50 DLC.
Back then you can buy one CD for $599 and it contained all those games in the Sonic Dreams collection.
Hahaha.
True value!
If you're lucky, you can might even find in your local thrift store.
Steam is a coward.
Sega is a fucking coward for not releasing it on Steam.
Hahaha.
Look, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That is my first quadruple A game.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hahaha.
Um...
Uh...
Oh no, I meant quadruple.
It's quintuple game.
But then thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Doki for making tomorrow rest day so we can see our therapist tomorrow.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey!
To tell them about the great time you had watching it, right?
Right guys?
Talk about your experience with how much fun you had enjoying this stream with your therapist.
Um...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This game was very, was indeed very kino.
Kubrick is envious.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright guys, I'm going to call it here now.
I love to chat with you guys longer but um...
I have a lot of work to do...
I know I keep saying that I haven't been able to do a long..
chatting stream with all of you guys.
Um...
Ah but I've just been so busy.
And ah... almost everyday.
And I hope that things calmed down soon.
So like we can have our usual chatting......
Ah chatting streams.
I had to cut it short.
But I hope you guys had a fun time watching me play Sonic Dreams Collection.
It's honestly one of the games I've been wanting to stream for a very long time.
So I'm happy to be able to finally experience this game with all of you.
But thank you guys.
I'll see you guys in the next one.
Uh...
I'll read this last Super Chat.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I listened to the stream while driving home from work today.
Audio only, so I had zero context for anything.
I just keep hearing you shout about feeding Sonic and break it down.
That is enough context that you need.
Don't worry.
That's all you need.
Do not worry.
But thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And then you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!